[Music]
I'm Scott Johnston I'm on hangouts team
thanks for coming to this session we're
gonna talk about team communications and
how we've been thinking about them in G
suite I think that one of the early
questions and we started working on
hangouts for productivity and for teams
was what really makes a successful team
and you may have seen us publish within
Google study called Aristotle where we
followed teams over many many years and
looked for what characteristics really
made a successful team we've done that
with our G suite customers as well and
that's really where we started in terms
of getting to the heart of what tools do
we need to provide teams with to make
them better teams and really to make a
team of 300 function like a team of
three and so one of the core there's a
number of takeaways but one of the key
ones for me was really that there wasn't
a lot of commonality between work styles
or particular particular behavior of the
teams in terms of being highly community
communicative or not not so or having a
certain set of personalities or having a
key mix of personalities but really in
the end the foundation of the most
successful teams that we found when we
did research was was that it was driven
by experiences so their their
foundations were were were what the
foundations were the base of of how how
they interacted and those those came
through and that they were able to have
emotional interactions so they were over
connect at a level that was usually
outside of work they had they could have
complex conversations that were that
were often heated and intense and people
felt safe having those kinds of
conversations and everyone seemed to
have a mix of work styles and so they
needed tools that supported those work
styles I had a great deal of control
over deciding when you were gonna work
when you weren't excuse me
and so that really was at the foundation
of the products that we built both from
Jam board through to hangouts and then
the other thing that we just have seen
and I don't need to tell you this it's
just this proliferation of tools that
that we can use now to be productive and
the more tools the better but but at the
same time people will get it we're
jumping between it having trouble
staying in the loop even something as
simple as a spreadsheet to track
something going on requires us to go to
that spreadsheet and there's a cognitive
step there and that that takes time and
so we really needed to figure out a way
to take communication and span it across
an ecosystem apps not just created some
new home that people would go to and
think that would solve the problem and
so what we announced this morning for
those of you who weren't at the keynote
is rebuilt hangouts and they're really
two components of team team productivity
that we focused on one was the virtual
room within within chat and then the
other was meetings face to face meetings
being key getting you into meetings and
there was a session earlier today maybe
some of you made on hangouts meet but
what this session is going to talk about
in a bit more detail is really how we
rebuilt hangouts chat the focus on team
productivity there were really three key
principles that we were working with one
was this ability to focus and there's a
there's a couple different aspects
around focus and teams one is your
ability to turn off whatever
communication tool that you're using so
it doesn't bother you and and you can
focus and and get into flow but also
even within the communication tool we
knew we had to figure out a way that
especially in real-time communications a
way to allow people to have
conversations that didn't interrupt
other conversations we've all seen this
in in consumer chat tools where
conversations will get woven and
fragmented really you'll be deep in one
conversation and another person will
bring up another topic and and that
fragments the conversation and often is
very
frustrating the users so we had to
figure out a way to to get a form of
focus on the ability to drill into a
particular topic without interrupting
others expression was key and this is
linked to what I was talking about
earlier around teams really needing to
be able to connect at an experience
level and an emotional level and then
the other core part was connecting
connecting the different tools bringing
them into the same same UI and and then
automation was was core and that that
really I know we talked at Google a lot
about machine learning but automation
actually starts earlier than machine
learning which is even our own products
for example take way too many steps for
you guys for you folks to do things if
you're in a six-person meeting creating
a Docs file and sharing it with those
six people is way too many steps right
now and so there's a course automation
focus we needed to have to start to
automatically do things that require too
many steps right now and that's that's
just a simple computer science problem
not a machine learning problem but we
knew we needed to start there and that's
where when you look at some of we talked
about this morning around the meet agent
that automatically schedule things
schedules things for you that's what
that's about is how do we eliminate as
many steps from your day as possible so
you can focus on the work at hand like
other products in G suite we knew we had
to have a strong focus on the enterprise
that's that's everything from security
to scalability and scalability doesn't
just mean classic fan out and and
ability to handle a lot of users but
also the ability to really work within
an organization in a scalable way and so
what you'll you'll learn about hangouts
chat is that the structures of it can be
wired up to Google Groups or connected
to central identity systems such that
you can have sila you can have rooms
configured around specific teams and
departments such that you're not dealing
with this giant pile of discussion rooms
but instead it's divided into topical
areas that that are relevant to your
team and what that means is that you can
scale across an enterprise and not just
not not just working in a small business
setting accessibility is core to
everything we do in in G suite and so
that's that's the foundation of
everything
in design from from the very beginning
reliability ease of use these are things
that are just part of our DNA and so
we're gonna talk now I'm gonna bring up
Mike who works with me in the hangouts
team and we're gonna walk through a more
detailed demo of hangouts chat from just
to dive into details beyond this morning
cool thank you guys we all know there's
this perfect process that you'll put in
place for a new idea a new products a
new project but never goes the way you
want it to go it's always a bit more
organic a bit more unstructured and
we're going to show you how a team at
tango toys uses the new hangouts chat to
plan a new product and get it out to the
market so we switch to the demo please
perfect so the first thing you'll notice
is we have a brand new web UI we just
built from the ground up completely
dedicated to just a chat interface so
just like hangouts today we have direct
messages where you can talk one-on-one
with somebody right now I'm talking with
Mandy she put a we're just having a
conversation about some of the existing
toys and I mentioned that I have a new
idea for a toy that I want to work on so
one of the main things we've added to
the new hangouts chat are rooms the
ability to centralize conversations
around projects or teams so instead of
actually thanks Mandy instead of
actually having a conversation right
here with Mandy I want to bring Varun
into the conversation as well and I want
to create a room for this new project so
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna go down
here click the Add button and create a
new room for the project
I'm going to add Mandy and Varun to the
room itself and put a Google Doc in the
room that talks a bit a little bit more
details about the project
now all I have to do to bring Mandy into
the room is just @mention her and Varun
as well and right away they're brought
into the room and and ready to go the
new hangouts chat also lets you add
Google Groups as remembers so if you use
Google Groups to manage identity across
your whole company you can reuse those
same groups to deploy hangouts chat to
your entire organization the other thing
you'll notice is that I just pasted a
Google Docs link we have deep
integration with Google Drive and Google
Docs so any link you post will
automatically get a beautiful thumbnail
rendered right in line so everybody can
quickly get back to files in addition to
the fact that we changed the file
permissions to automatically match the
room so everyone in the room can have
access and we remove the mundane task of
requesting access and giving access so
people could just start working
immediately so this right now this is
what we like to call the seed of the
team right we have an idea we have some
content we have some people we have some
conversation and the thing you'll notice
is we didn't need to bother IT about
this we didn't need to say hey can you
please create an email audience for us
or hey can you provision something new
honors on-prem filer for us we just got
together started working immediately and
you can see right now everyone's busy at
work
Mandy's putting a bunch of stuff into
the chat she put a projection
spreadsheet into the chat rooms putting
a Gantt chart into the chat for how we
can actually get this project moving
forward and we recognize that when
you're working on projects you're going
to be talking about different things so
one thing you'll notice is that rooms
are threaded we let you separate the
conversation and keep context around
different things so the conversation
about the projections
spreadsheet can be separated from the
conversation about the Gantt chart and
threads are not just great for
separating out different topics within
it but it also helps separate the
unimportant chitchat that happens like
where do you want to go for lunch or
what movie did you see this weekend from
the important work now these threads are
not meant to feel heavyweight they're
they're not meant to feel like something
you need to manage or you need to
organize we don't want to put work on
the user so the way
work is whenever a new thread gets
updated it bumps down to the bottom and
you'll get notified and you'll be able
to see all the things you haven't read
so over time what ends up happening is
all the important discussions bubble up
to the bottom and all the unimportant
stuff or the stuff that's been resolved
just kind of floats into the ether of
the chat history so you'll see right
here that there's a bunch of
conversation going on with many of a
rune on the Gantt chart and I'm sure
everyone in the audience is experienced
this before where you text a friend they
text you back you text them again they
text you back and eventually you're like
okay wait please just stop let's just
talk on the telephone this is taking
forever
so we recognize this happens at work all
the time as well so what we've done is
we've deeply integrated Hangouts meet
and to hang out to chat so when I want
to just stop the chat conversation I can
click this button down here and insert a
video meeting write a little note post
it into the chat room and now a video
meeting was created with one click I
could jump into the meeting and I'm put
into a greenroom where I can see how I
look see who else is in the meeting and
then I can jump into the meeting and
you'll notice Mandy's in the meeting
right now and we could we could get
started so this is hanging out to me
like Scott mentioned earlier hopefully
you guys caught the session earlier we
talked about it a little bit at the
keynote itself everybody left we talked
about it at the keynote itself so not
gonna spend a lot of time talking about
it right now but at a high level it's
specifically designed with enterprise
use in mind so completely new code base
less code means faster CPU speed better
performance and specific enterprise
features like one-click to present the
ability for non Google Apps customers to
dial into a meeting and the ability for
people to dial in on the road with a
dialing telephone number so we were able
to take this low bandwidth conversation
in chat and move it to a high bandwidth
conversation and video and resolve it
very fast so sometimes passed and I want
to add Nicole to this project so I'm
going to do that
on the new hangouts chat mobile apps can
we switch to the Blowfish and please
great so wonderful so all I have to do
like before when I want to add someone
to the meeting to the room excuse me yes
I just need to add mentioned them to
bring them in so I'll type Nicole's name
I'll add her acknowledge she's gonna be
in the room and now she's brought into
the room and this is where rooms really
shine so when you onboard new employees
there's always a ramp-up period right
you you need to tell the new employees
what they should be reading what
everybody is working on the way your
team works you know they spend some time
rifling through some outdated filers
looking at stale documents that really
are kind of irrelevant and don't even
matter anymore but the great thing about
this now is that it closes in this room
she could see the most recent
conversations she could jump right into
the most recent conversations and she
could see all the files as well and the
most recent ones are probably the most
relevant ones as well and like I
mentioned before because we have deep
drive integration Nicole already has
access to these files so we don't need
to retroactively Lee give her access to
the files which is great so over time
this room becomes very much like a
centralized team hub a team repository
where all the important conversations
you have live all of the files you've
shared live as well so we've indexed all
that and made it completely searchable
so when I want to search just click on
the little search button and we know
through all of our drive research and
our gmail research you can never
remember the file name of a file someone
shared with you or ever remember the
subject line of an email but you always
have those other little nuggets of
information like who sent them who sent
the file or what kind of thing they sent
so while you can search for key word
what we've seen in our trusted tester as
many people actually just search by
person or search by type so when I want
to I could get back to that document
that I just posted earlier in the room
itself cool we switch back to the demo
please
so we know that with chat apps
notifications can be a problem so we
want to make sure you don't feel like
you're working all the time we have very
granular chat controls to let you dial
up or dial down the notifications to as
much as you want so if you want to be in
the loop all the time you can say send
me everything but if you don't you can
just say okay only notify me when I was
specifically mentioned someone was
trying to get my attention so you know
it's a good time to write back and not
only that we have notification controls
at the thread level as well so when
there becomes a really unwieldy thread
that's a little noisy or maybe a thread
that is a little bit you know not even
relevant to you like perhaps I don't
care about this Gantt chart all I have
to do is just mute this thread right
here and now I'll no longer get any
notifications in that thread at all so
let's fast forward one one year these
color blocks they're in the market and
we are working with a bunch of other
tools too to help us and with these
tools we've integrated them using the
hangouts platform so they're actually in
the chat UI itself so let me switch over
to the sales leads room just to give an
example so our team uses Zendesk for
high-touch distribution partners so
these are folks that are really
important and we want to know whenever
there's an issue with them so we can for
their ticket and respond promptly so
Zendesk is built the Zendesk bot that
notifies people whenever a high-priority
item comes in so you can see right here
that something was posted a
high-priority ticket was created from
toy Mart and the issue is that a bunch
of people are returning this specific
toy set because parts are missing so we
need to fix that
and we need to rectify the situation
with them so they could be happy so
right away Patrick just said can you
take this and forwarded that over to
Scott so he can take it and jump on it
our team also uses prosper work CRM to
keep track of current customers and
profess prospective customers so I'm
going to switch over to prosper works
now this is our sales pipeline so you
can see all
the opportunities that we have and
broken up into all the different stages
right now we just had a pitch with
dinosaur hill toys in New York City and
the pitch went really well
so they said they're going to carry the
color blocks in their store so what
we're going to do is we're gonna move
this dinosaur Hill toys from
presentation into contract scent because
that's the stage ascend right now so
we've moved it and now when you go over
to the chat UI you'll notice in real
time a notification was posted saying
dinosaur Hill toys was changed from
presentation to contract sent and now
anyone could start commenting on this
like Mandy just said I think that's
fireworks right so Mandy just posted
some fireworks
Varun called me a superstore which is
very sweet so I could do that in real
time and not only do we want to make it
so third parties can push things into
the chat UI we want to make it so users
can actually pull data from third
parties into the chat UI as well so when
I want to find out what my sales numbers
were last month all I have to do is talk
to the prosper work spot
and I write back letting me know that I
closed a total of forty three hundred
dollars worth of sales last month so can
we switch back to the presentation
please
so we're teaming with a number of
companies to build BOTS on the hangouts
chat platform from a number of business
functions so regardless of if you work
in sales or marketing customer service
HR the tools you use every single day
will be even more useful to you in
hangouts chat let me switch back to the
presentation please demo sorry
great so not only can you work with
these other third-party services we
allow you to easily build bux using Apps
Script which means that you can write
very custom workflows specific to your
company and deploy them to your entire
domain so you could do things like
perhaps you have a ticketing system
that's just custom internal to your
company you could write a bot that lets
users submit tickets straight from the
chat UI you could deploy to all the
users in your domain so on day one they
can use it without having to go to
another external tool so we also use the
chat platform to the hangouts platform
excuse me to build our own BOTS so like
Scott mentioned earlier we demoed the
meet bot at the keynote and the meet bot
uses natural language processing and
machine intelligence to automatically
schedule a meeting for us so I'm going
to switch over to the Laurence
coordination room and I think Mandy is
going to show us how it'll work so she
asked the meet bought to find a time
today and it wrote back
with a card now there's actually a lot
of really intelligent things happening
here the meet but understands things
like today tomorrow next week next month
two months from now it understands when
people are on vacation when people are
in the office it understands what time
zones people are in so if I have a
meeting with someone who's Erick we're
not scheduling that meeting at 11:30
p.m. for them you can do other things
like reschedule the meeting
so Mandy move the meeting to tomorrow it
looked at the calendars every scheduled
meeting - tomorrow
it supports other commands in the future
like canceling the meeting adding
additional people to the meeting meeting
right now
and also just booking the room for you
if you want to just huddle really quick
we're also going to be building other
BOTS in the future that are very
intelligent on top of the hangouts chat
platform that we're gonna be excited to
share with you in the coming months so
I'm gonna turn it back over to Scott
jump back into the slides thanks Mike
that was great
so that's uh that's at a high level just
a walk through of of the new hangouts
chat and three main areas that we
focused on direct messages which we
support now and classic hangouts along
with presents we added virtual team
rooms for huddling around projects teams
topics and a new hangouts platform that
supports everything from app scripting
with Google Apps Script through to
intelligent BOTS some of the key
features that we're launching our range
from search everything from free text
search to as Mike touched on filtering
by people and types of files custom
workflows with Apps Script Docs and
drive integration the hangouts platform
itself the meet bot that comes with
intelligent scheduling intelligent with
hangouts chat and does intelligent
scheduling and enterprise Enterprise
readiness across the hangouts platform
so high-level looking at helping you
connect easily get stuff done and be
ready for your enterprise
[Music]
[Music]